judging by these last couple weeks alone
2023 is quite a Majors year
[Music]
ridiculous I'm cutting that out I might
keep it so as the title implies or
absolutely clearly states Creed 3 is the
third Creed movie directed by Michael B
Jordan is actually his directorial debut
in this chapter of Adonis Creed's life
Adonis Creed is enjoying retirement
enjoying the fruits of his labor he's
absolutely earned it then an old friend
from his past named Dame played by
Jonathan major shows up Dame was an
up-and-coming boxer went to prison never
got his shot but now he wants that shot
let the Friendship the bonding the
catching up and the tension commence
still gonna talk about him out the gate
why because we just talked about
Jonathan Majors as Kang also in my
Quantum Mania review I said Jonathan
Majors was great I just wish the movie
around him was better well a week later
I got to see that Jonathan majors and
Michael B Jordan have great chemistry
together also I love the fact that this
movie really does make you empathize
with Dane dude just wants the shot he
never got you totally see why Adonis
Creed's like I feel obligated to help
him which in turn lays the groundwork
and you feel the sense of obligation
when things go bad now there was a
little bit of the oh why is Rocky not in
this movie conversation a little while
ago after seeing the movie absolutely
Rocky Balboa the character Sylvester
Stallone not in this movie but after
seeing the movie I want to give the
movie credit for that granted and Rocky
3 when Rocky has to get his mojo back
you know and he has to take out clever
Lang Apollo Creed helps him out it would
have been cool to see Rocky come in and
help Adonis out but for the character
Creed in these Creed movies that would
have made it feel like he was still in
Rocky's Shadow this is a movie that
makes a clear statement without making
the statement to the camera I mean just
in terms of action and execution makes a
statement that Adonis Creed is his own
man the Creed movies are not in the
shadow of the Rocky movies they still
mention the fight between Rocky Balboa
and Apollo Creed after the fight's done
I I'm pretty sure I heard that theme
that plays at the end of Rocky fights
reminds you that it's in the same world
absolutely but I felt like Creed 3 made
the biggest attempt and success at
having Adonis Creed and the Creed movies
feel like their own movies and there
were a couple of creative choices going
into this movie I was just looking okay
if this movie is even competently
directed Michael B Jordan's fine we'll
see more from him but there were a
couple of moments where he aims to put
his mark on the movies one fight in
particular where all the ambience goes
down you're just in the ring with the
two of them it was a cool moment where
they were just in the zone there was
nothing else but them there was no crowd
music sound effects cheering I will say
there are moments of pacing issues in
this movie I run into that feeling of
things I wanted to know more about that
I feel would have been interesting to
elaborate on I feel like the movie skips
right by it maybe it's a grass is always
greener on the other side kind of
scenario where I'm like well because I
didn't see that other stuff I wish I did
but the movie would have been four hours
so I guess something has to give and
I'll be completely honest with you I'm
kind of having a hard time
framing this
you know like formulating a way to
illustrate my point I'm about to say I
guess that's the point of it is it's a
very subjective preference for me rather
than an objective critique on the film
for me Adonis Creed's Ark and his
journey is most interesting when it's
synonymous with his journey through the
boxing world the character drama and the
boxing in relation to that character is
very much interwoven but for most of
this movie Adonis Creed's retired so the
boxing journey is actually Jonathan
Major's character but the personal
Journeys with Adonis Creed's characters
so there's a separation granted all of
it is leading to this big boxing match
showdown at the end and I suppose that's
a byproduct of telling this story of
Adonis Creed's life in this phase of
Adonis Creed's life I mean he is retired
he's coasting his career is kind of on
cruise control he's doing good but
problems could arise oh hey the old
friend that I feel responsible for and
I'm gonna the president yup here we go
feels like James T Kirk when he was an
admiral it's like but I liked you better
as the captain just just like that now
all my personal Heroes Journey boxing
Journey interwoven [__] aside the
movie works so that's all you need to
know is whether or not it works whether
or not the movie's a good time Michael B
Jordan and Jonathan Majors make sure
that the Chemistry Between the actors
the tension between the characters it is
all there and it makes for a good time
it's a movie about Taking Chances
forgiving forgiving others as well as
yourself but it's also a movie about
taking responsibility I had myself a
great time in Creed 3 no alcohol
required I will say this last few months
been doing really good at working out
eating healthier
I need to do more
all right so Creed Three have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
everyone's talking to Adonis in this
movie like they were talking to Rocky in
the movie Rocky Balboa like they're not
as young as you used to be we got to use
your strengths I was like where how the
wow how [__] old am I scared me I
felt like I had to get my Affairs in
order make out a will after I got out of
the movie